hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to oxygen not included
so we've got a really unique situation
going on here we've got water flowing
down and I need to prioritize another
like channel for it to go down so I'm
just going to pool there so I don't know
why just gonna make that a nine dig okay
so they're going to dig that out they
need to get food obviously the next step
has to be food after these repairs get
made they're breathing nothing but
contaminated oxygen which sucks I know
but there's not a whole lot that I can
do about it right now but yeah
immediately after that was just about to
start boy but at least we're going
somewhere so with with clean water with
clean water comes oxygen through water
like formation things stuff whatever the
technical term you want to call that
that's what it is that's usually the
broken two little broken little broken
okay so now water hopefully anyway
should go there we try to make some sort
of okay well they can't get there now
which sucks but okay oh god people are
starving no don't starve and go to bed
no come on just make food god damnit
make food oh my god makes food makes
food make food I know everyone's hungry
I'm aware I'm aware of this
man at least this is making good water
it's actually pumping out three like
about three kilograms of water a second
which is a lot of water a good good good
amount of water I mean it's still going
to take some time before it gets through
all this but at least we'll have that
and then I'm going to cut through here
get another channel of contaminated
water through there now that I can deal
with that okay get water just nothing
but food just get food don't die get
food get food get food food food get
food I get food maybe I could just turn
these off since they they won't be a
draw on power since they don't have any
I'll just keep these two on and that way
these will stay off so that so these
will stay off so they don't draw excess
power well go get food don't starve go
get food there should be no other
priority besides just getting food even
these need to be set to 60 I'll shut the
six still don't starve just for that I'm
going to put food at a constant seven
that way I don't need to change it back
and forth every time please tell me
we're not going to die
the bubbles eat the bubbles eat the
bubbles eat bubbles eat eat bubbles
bubbles eat bubbles have you eaten
bubbles why have you not eaten Big E
what are you doing
you just get some power oh my god oh
don't die don't die don't die it's right
there it's so easy
he can bubble why have you not eaten yet
bubble just go eat are you kidding me
what the [ __ ] is going on why are they
not eating why are they not eating I am
I can't do anything else to make them
eat
oh god bubbles why are you repairing the
six people starving them there should be
no reason for six people to starve now
why are six people starving now just eat
who died
god damn it dick what the [ __ ]
Vic are you goddamn serious beak there
was no reason to do that don't tell me
this
god damn it bubbles what the [ __ ] are
you [ __ ] serious don't go to bed what
is happening to these people why are
they not eating why the [ __ ] aren't they
eating just as I was about to get
everything under way just as I was
getting things going it's like it's a
non-stop battle every single goddamn
second of this it's just a constant
battle there's no winning this is no
winning one person olive do not die
olive olives please Olive please don't
die olives don't do it please eat
something eat something eat something
stop stretching water and eat something
all of you can't die I know you olive
you don't die Olive eat something stop
being selfless for one second and eat
something
oh if you're so selfless what are you
doing in please eat something
colic what are you doing Alvin just eat
something
am i literally just going to watch allof
starve to death as she constantly tries
to provide everyone else with food just
please
olive Hollis cannot reach food why she's
dead
the only thing I can do is the problem
is running out of water
that is the main issue I can't grow
things here it's too hot and I can't
produce oxygen I don't have enough water
and I can't send them to get more slime
they'll starve so the problem is it's
using tons of water it's using tons of
them not just a little bit of water it's
using tons of water
so the problem wasn't the number of
microbe mushers the problem was getting
that water up there to them so then so
then the answer isn't having more of
them up here it's having more of them
closer to the water but I'm almost out
of water anyway [ __ ] what's the answer
here everyone is going to starve I can't
[ __ ] make I can't make any goddamn
meal would cuz it's too hot she was
already just starving that that's the
long and the short of people are just
starving they are this was inside more
people died Dan is just dead the bodies
are piling up bubbles is just down here
dying I have to do
the breaking axe they broke every single
one of these every one of these are you
kidding me god damn it it's a
never-ending nightmare just let me help
you I know how to do it now
god damn it you've got to be kidding me
I know how to help why is it so hard
stinky god damn it it's always the ones
that I care about
ah god damn it this is the episode of
death
there's the episode of literally nothing
but death not everyone is starving I
just can't make enough food I just can't
make enough food more people are gonna
die there's nothing I can do about these
are gonna grow slowly
nothing we can do
it's going to reach a point where on I
can't bring anyone in are they gonna do
nothing it's going to reach a point of
equilibrium when there's you know when
there's enough people that there's not a
food shortage anymore because everyone's
dying or everyone has died but my lips
get more people meet up did me die I'll
just get Turner
I'm sorry I'm so sad like I'm not joking
when I say like I don't want these guys
to die just weird I just it's not like I
actually have physical feelings for him
but it's just it's such [ __ ]
just surrounded by nothing but death I
need this thing to get more like be in
the contaminated oxygen enough such that
it makes more slime because it comes
down here every once a while and then it
flows back up I think what I got to do
is I gotta like I kind of like destroyed
this stuff kind of perforate the bottom
of it so people can still jump across it
but you know
it was the starving the six two more got
two more people died
two more someone died building a
gravestone I thought I had this turned
around I thought I had it figured out
and just all of this [ __ ] happened
so the only thing I could do that could
make microbe crushers in here and then
destroy all the other one these are
closer to the water so they would
naturally be able to you know like
naturally you just logically be able to
make faster your distance so if we set
these at a high priority to make these I
mean I know it's not a good use of the
resources that we have I'm well aware of
that I wish it weren't the case and I
wish we didn't have bodies really piling
up goddamn in the [ __ ] overheated
overheated is it cousin
is it cuz of bubbles rotting body got a
bit more graves numbers
we're down to six four more people has
died safety may Virgil Woodrow I don't I
thought I had it I thought I had it with
that [ __ ] filter it provided more
water how did it go from I had plenty of
food how did this happen
God we can't make power we can't do
anything we're not repairing things I
can't make any food they can't even
repair there's literally just going to
die the me I should have been making
meal wood before god dammit god dammit
they're just gonna tear themselves apart
until it's the end there's nothing else
to do they are all going to die I built
all this infrastructure I built all of
this in the hopes that I would turn this
around and I still fail there's no
coming back from this this is not
there's no coming back from this
mozzarella extending forever in his bed
he's a new arrival I know what I did
wrong I know what I did wrong because
obviously I didn't know what I was doing
number one but I know what I did wrong
in terms of the way that I built into
the layout I was fighting a hundred
percent stress the entire game and I was
doing it I was so close to succeeding
and then food gets me
god damn it I'm devastated I really am
I'm really am I really am devastated
I like everything was against me yes
everything was again like I still can't
believe this game is in pre-alpha it's
not even a beta and [ __ ] I love it I
love this game I love this game I can't
stop playing this game until it removed
all choice for me and then it ended
everything for me man I tried I was
learning as I was going you can't follow
me for that I don't think you do I think
you guys are on my side for it but I'm
like I'm complaining de village to fate
itself you can't fault me for trying
like I was learning as outgoing and I
was loving every minute of learning it
and I haven't had a game like this that
makes me just itch to play it more and
even right now I want to go back and I
want to dive in and I want to start over
again with everything that I learned and
I will do that not today so thank you
everybody so much for watching I hope
you guys have enjoyed this thus far I
tried really hard and I've learned a lot
and if I go back in there I'm gonna make
a freaking amazing base but I scratch
the surface of it I didn't even get past
the first volume of the normal base
materials I didn't even go far enough to
see where we could have gone hopefully
we will - thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
[Music]